المشكله الحقيقيه حقيقه هي تدني
الدرجات الحراره دائما في الليل الحراره
على الاقل اربع درجات خمس درجات تحت الصفر
في بعض الليالي تكون ناقص ثمانيه ناقص
تسعه ناقص عشره هذه درجات الحراره
المتدنيه اكبر مشكله يعني انا انا برايي
نعم ومن خلال مشاهدات هي اكبر مشكله
يعاني منها السكان نعم هناك خيمه هناك
دائما هناك
خصوصا من لم يتلقى مساعدات نعم مع الاسف
وهؤلاء هناك بعض العائلات التي صورنا
صورنا معها مقابلات يوم امس لقناه العربيه
لم يتلقوا مساعدات او خيم احضروا خيم
بدائيه ومحترئه لا يمكن ان تقي
البرد ودرجات الحراره القاسيه يقفون خارج
الخيمه يحضرون الخشب والحطب ويشعلون النار
ليتدفا الاطفال وكبار السن حقيقه كانت
مشاهد مؤثره وصعبه يعني معاناه قاسيه جدا
جدا في هنا في اصلاحيه سواء للذين يعيشون
في الخيام او حتى من لم تصله خيام